I don't think I'm the only one with
a little bit of PTSD these days.
For a lot of us that lived through
those really dark days, suddenly,
here we are again with a virus you
can't see randomly affecting people,
life being put on hold,
all sorts of things changing.
Around the time of the lockdown here in
San Francisco, it suddenly occurred to me
that this is going to be
the second pandemic of my life.
And really, no one should have
to live through more than one.
[MUSIC]
All those years ago in San Francisco,
in the early 80s, and mid 80s,
it was a really dark time.
I had just finished Stanford Business
School and had taken care of a friend and
a classmate who died during school.
And moved up to San Francisco without
really thinking much about a career and
a job, a little heartbroken,
a little bit lost, and
kind of stumbled into
the middle an epidemic.
The Castro back then was horrible.
You'd walk down the street and you'd pass
dozens of people who you knew you were
probably never going to see again.
The country didn't seem to be
responding or didn't seem to be caring.
When some friends and
I started the AIDS Memorial Quilt,
it was really a cry for help.
It was really a way to
be heard at a time when
we all thought we were going
to die alone and forgotten.
A friend of a friend, Cleve Jones,
came to me in 1987 and
said he had this crazy idea for a quilt
and some way to reach Middle America with
something that's not threatening and
feels warm and comforting.
And you think of your grandmother
when someone says quilt, and
that wasn't the world we were
living in with AIDS right then.
It was a much different world where people
were either there's you and there's us,
and we don't have it and you do,
and that's all there is to it.
Almost immediately, I thought this is
an idea that's really going to resonate.
We said we were going to do that first
display at the March on Washington for
Gay and Lesbian Rights in October of 87,
four months after we decided to start
building this thing, which was crazy.
And I think I thought we would do this for
a little while, and we'd make our point,
and that would be the end.
And I don't think we were prepared for
the beauty of the quilts.
We had been making something that were
basically bed sheets to make a protest
statement.
And suddenly we had mothers all over
the country, sending us panels for
their dead son, expecting us to preserve
them and care for them in perpetuity.
I never thought it would become my life's
work, but it has become my life's work.
In the middle of all of this COVID,
when it first happened,
I wasn't the only one that
was kind of looking for
a way to be helpful, a way to do something
which has always been kind of my mode.
Gert McMullin, who'd been very
involved in sewing together
many of the panels in the quilt for
years, was feeling the same way.
She used to be able to go into
hospital rooms in the 80s and
be with dying friends.
She just couldn't stand that
she couldn't touch people and
she couldn't be up close with people.
Finally she said, I'm going to go
into the workshop, it's empty,
there's nobody else there.
And I'm going to start making some face
masks and we can give them away to people.
I made a phone call to an old friend, and
it turned out she was working at
an agency that was desperate for masks.
This project has really opened my
eyes to see how many vulnerable and
at risk populations there are in an
epidemic like this, in a homeless shelter,
in a youth rehab program.
People are right there up
close with each other and
you can't get that kind of distance.
The AIDS Memorial Quilt has
gone from a protest banner and
something we were going to take to
Washington to make a difference for
one day to a national treasure.
I mean, it's the largest community
arts project in the world.
More people have worked on
the quilt than built the pyramids.
And a lot of what we did at
the time was not just the fabric.
We inspired people to do something,
anything,
to express what they were going through,
to tell their stories.
And I think now about where we are with
this mask project and it's the same thing.
We may make 2 or 3,000 masks and
that may save some lives.
I'd much rather have
this be a catalyst for
other people to feel like I
can find something to do.
I can get out of my house and
go help stuff food at the food bank.
If we can do something
simple like make masks,
you can do something simple,
like find a way to be helpful.
And that's what I'd much rather be
remembered for, being that catalyst,
than for just doing some sewing.
[MUSIC]